Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Dir. Was haben wir jetzt? Einundzwanzigste Ausgabe. Äh steht heute an und äh heute in so einem großen Kreis wie nie zuvor. Wir haben Gäste im Studio begrüßen wir ein weiteres Mal Andre, Andre Meister, hallo.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Und äh in Brüssel haben wir unseren Korrespondenten an Start gebracht. Wir begrüßen äh Ralf Ralf Benrath, hallo.
Guten Morgen.
Ist ähm Mitglied im Verein digitale Gesellschaft und wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter des Europaparlamentabgeordneten Jan-Philipp Albrecht.
Und ganz manchmal schreibe ich auch noch bei Netzpolitik Punkt org, aber ich habe da ja kaum noch Zeit dafür.
Genau und Ralf jetzt ist Datenschützer.
Genannt werden. Oder gilt das heutzutage schon als Schimpfwort? Gut.
Nur bei uns nicht. Kannst auch Internetversteher sagen.
Gut, also wir haben hier eine große Runde von Internetverstehen. Und äh ja
Warum haben wir dich angerufen? Äh du hast Informationen für uns zum Thema Fluggastdatenabkommen oder auch PNR genannt. Da haben wir hier schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen und da gab's heute eine neue, äh nicht heute, aber gestern, glaube ich, eine neue Entwicklung.
Ja, das ist eine Geschichte, die läuft schon seit Jahren. Ähm die USA haben nach dem ersten September zweitausendeins angefangen,
oder sich von den Fluglinien ähm Daten zu holen über die Passagiere, die in die USA einreisen
und äh damit quasi eine kombinierte Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Rasterfahndung zu machen. Das heißt, sie haben die irgendwie auf äh ewig gespeichert. Ähm also direkt an die Behörden übertragen, ne? Security da, die Transportation Security Administration
ähm haben die ewig gespeichert und auch noch ähm mit Risikoprofilen abgeglichen. Also quasi Rasterfahndung auf Deutsch, ne.
Um dann zu gucken wer es vielleicht gefährlich, wer darf aufs Flugzeug und wer darf nicht oder sowas, dann kam zwischendurch raus, das machen sie auch bei Flugzeugen, die bloß amerikanischen Luftraum überfliegen
ähm oder teilweise sogar bei welchen, die nur irgendwie in die Nähe kommen. Jetzt vor kurzem gab's eine Meldung, dass wenn man zum Beispiel von Europa nach Kuba fliegt
man irgendwie auch in amerikanischen Datenbanken landet. So,
als das äh die Europäer mitbekommen haben, haben sie gesagt, finden wir nicht so toll, ist vielleicht nicht so ganz im Einklang mit europäischen Datenschutzbestimmungen und so. Und und Vorratsdatenbeschränkungen und so weiter.
Und dann wurde ähm verhandelt
mit den Amerikanern über ein Abkommen, um das sozusagen auf eine rechtliche Grundlage zu stellen. Ähm da gab's das erste zweitausendvier, das hat dann der Europäische Gerichtshof gekillt, weil das äh auf einer falschen Rechtsgrundlage passiert ist. Dann gab's zweitausendsieben noch eins. Das bestand im Prinzip nur aus einem Brief, dass die Partner Security, wo drin stand, wir machen alles super
und dann noch ein kleiner Text, der sagte, ja auf den Brief stützen wir uns und jetzt ist alles gut. Und dieses Abkommen ähm ist dann zweitausend
äh zehn dem Europäischen Parlament vorgelegt worden zur Abstimmung
weil ähm mit dem Lissabon-Vertrag jetzt das Europäische Parlament ja über internationale Abkommen mitreden muss, also immer mitbestimmen muss, genau wie bei Actaja zum Beispiel auch
das Parlament hat dann gesagt vor zwei Jahren, nee finden wir nicht so toll das Abkommen, verhandelt man neu,
Dann wurde neu verhandelt und jetzt liegt seit letzten November das neue Abkommen auf dem Tisch
und ähm das ist leider gestern dann im Parlament auch angenommen worden.
Mit äh welchen Mehrheiten.
Relativ deutlich. Ich habe die Zahl nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf, ich glaube vierhundertneun dafür und zwohundertsechsundzwanzig dagegen der Größenordnung. Ähm die Innenkommissarin hat dann gleich getwittert, äh einundsechzig Prozent der Abgeordneten waren dafür.
Ja, es ist tragisch.
Ähm vor allem an den, wer hat uns verraten? An den Sozialdemokraten. Allerdings muss man da fairerweise sagen, nicht an den Deutschen, also die SPD war wirklich dagegen,
die zuständige Schattenberichterstatterin der sozialdemokratischen Fraktion ist auch aus Deutschland, Birgit Sippel, die hat auch ihrer Fraktion empfohlen, dagegen zu stimmen
sie konnte sich aber nicht durchsetzen bei den anderen äh Nationen und ähm dann hast du eben so äh spanische, sozialdemokraten, die eine lange Geschichte der Terrorbekämpfung haben mit der Etat und so,
die britischen Labour Abgeordneten, die unter Toni Blair auch schon selber einen Überwachungsstaat aufgebaut haben und so diverse andere, die haben dann einfach gesagt, nee, ähm das,
finden wir jetzt gut, das muss man machen. Ähm.
Ja, es gab dann ein bisschen äh Spaltung auch bei den Liberalen. Die Deutschen, Liberalen haben überwiegend dagegen gestimmt, bis auf, glaube ich, eine Enthaltung oder so
Aber ähm da hat auch ein Drittel der liberalen Fraktionen auch ein paar Engländer und sowas ähm dafür gestimmt. Das sind immer so ein bisschen die nationalen Besonderheiten, die Liberalen in Großbritannien sind ja zum Beispiel,
äh in der Koalition jetzt mit den Konservativen und kippen dann auch öfter mal auf der Seite. Dumm laufen.
Kannst du nur mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen, welche Daten denn da jetzt gespeichert werden? Für wie lange und unter welchen Voraussetzungen, die die in die USA übermittelt werden?
Die werden immer übermittelt ähm,
soll jetzt nach dem sogenannten Pushverfahren gehen, das heißt die Airlines schicken die aktiv ans Security. Ähm bisher gab's Pull, das heißt äh die HS hatte selber einen direkten Zugriff auf die Server
und konnte sich da eigentlich rausziehen, was es wollte. Ähm gepusht, natürlich gibt's immer noch Ausnahmeklausel in dem Ding, wo drin steht, in besonderen Umständen dürften es immer noch Pullen, ne, ist ja klar.
Ähm die Daten selber sind so diverse Daten halt über über das Reiseticket, wann es ausgestellt wurde, wann der Reisedatum ist, Name,
Aber dann eben auch sowas wie äh Freakland Freak und Flyer Informationen, Namen von Mitreisenden, ähm Kontaktinformationen, also Handynummer, Adresse und so weiter. Auch natürlich dann das Hotel, was man da vielleicht gebucht hat oder ähnlich ist
ähm Zahlungsinformationen, also Kreditkartennummer und so weiter, ähm Reisebüro, wo man das gekauft hat,
dann jeweils upgedatet der Status, also ob man schon eingecheckt ist und ähnliches, wie viel Gepäck man mitschleppt, äh welche Sitznummer man hatte und dann aber eben auch so offene Felder wie General Remarks.
Also allgemeine Anmerkungen. Da kann dann alles drin stehen, da kann auch drin stehen, ist ein anstrengender Kunde oder sowas oder ist kein Schweinefleisch.
Was heißt denn Mitreisende? Das heißt, es gibt auch explizit so eine reißt gemeinsam mit Informationen oder wie? Wie wird die denn generiert, wenn man gemeinsam einen Sitz bucht oder äh.
Weiß nicht genau, wie das intern bei den Fluglinien da in den Computersystemen läuft, aber anscheinend gibt's da irgendwie so ein Feld, was immer anzeigt, die gehören zusammen.
Familien wahrscheinlich.
Kauft oder so, ich weiß, da kann man natürlich also Spezialist aus San Francisco, den wir auch schon mal ein paar Mal in Brüssel hatten. Ähm der sagt immer, ähm diese PNR-Daten sagen eigentlich, wer mit wem schläft. Weil dann kannst du gucken, wer ähm hat zusammen das Ticket gebucht
wer sitzt vielleicht auch nebeneinander im gleichen Flieger? Und haben sie dann hinterher ein oder zwei Hotelzimmer.
Mhm. Na, ist ja beruhigend, das für unsere Sicherheit jetzt so gesorgt wird. Mhm.
Ja und äh die Daten werden gespeichert für fünfzehn Jahre,
da ist jetzt auch ein bisschen fünfzehn.
Ne, also Karlsruhe hat ja bei der Vorratsdatenentscheidung vor zwei Jahren gesagt, sechs Monate ist so gerade mal eben irgendwie das, was
nur noch halbwegs ertragen könnten, unter Umständen mit besonderen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen und
die Daten nur bei den Providern gespeichert bleiben erstmal, bis ein Anfangsverdacht da ist, äh jetzt werden sie halt erstmal an die Behörden übertragen und auch noch gerastet.
Rund fünfzehn Jahre gespeichert. Äh Mainz drömt, die Innenkommissarin ist jetzt immer rumgelaufen, letzten Wochen hat behauptet, die werden ja nur für Terrorismusbekämpfung fünfzehn Jahre gespeichert und für normale Kriminalitätsbekämpfung, zehn Jahre.
Blödsinn, weil man weiß ja vorher nicht, äh für welche Zwecke man sie braucht irgendwann. Ähm.
Das sind Terrorist, den speichern wir fünfzehn Jahre.
Nach zehn Jahren darf man sie nur noch verwenden für Terrorismusbekämpfung
Aber die ersten zehn Jahre auch für ähm normale Bekämpfung von Straftaten und dann sind auch noch so Öffnungsklausel in dem Abkommen drin, ähm dass man sie auch für für Grenzsicherungszwecke benutzen kann,
Äh und für sozusagen alles, was irgendwie ein Gericht anordnet in den USA.
Ohnehin ist es doch so, dass das eigentlich jetzt jede US-Behörde, die haben kann, oder? Gibt's da, da gibt's ja gar keine äh gar keine Regelung irgendwie oder gibt's da irgendwelche Regelungen? Welche Behörde zu unter die, die zu verwahren hat. Ich hatte das.
Die werden äh geliefert immer ans äh an die Transportation security administration. Das ist ein Teil von und die dürfen aber dann auch äh wenn es ihnen irgendwie nötig erscheint zur Bekämpfung von Straftaten und so weiter an andere Behörden weitergegeben werden.
Und das bezieht sich jetzt nur auf Flüge in die USA oder bezieht sich das auf mehr.
Oder über amerikanischen Luftraum.
Ah ja, war US-amerikanischen Luftraum.
Ja. Äh vielleicht eine Sache noch, das ähm was jetzt auch so ein bisschen in den Medien äh etwas verwirrend rüberkam, ähm oder auch die ähm behauptet hat, dass die Daten nach sechs Monaten ja an
werden oder so oder pseudonymisiert. Ähm das ist großer Quatsch. Die werden nach sechs Monaten in Anführungszeichen maskiert. So steht's im Text. Das heißt, die bleiben weiterhin im Klartext in der Datenbank gespeicher
es kriegt sie bloß nicht mehr, jeder normale Officer irgendwie angezeigt, sondern das geht dann irgendwie nur an die höheren oder so. Aber die werden weder in der Datenbank irgendwie anonymisiert noch pseudonymisiert oder sowas
Und nach unserer Einschätzung verstößt das halt gegen mindestens zwei Urteile des Bundesverfassungsgerichts, ne? Das äh Vorratsdatenurteil und das Urteil zur Rasterfahndung zweitausendsechs.
Was könnte denn das jetzt für konkrete äh Konsequenzen haben? Ich meine, wenn das jetzt wirklich gegen unsere Verfassung verstößt, welche Hebel hat denn Deutschland an der Stelle?
Schwierig. Ähm also Deutschland selber hat sich enthalten, als das im Rat angenommen wurde im Innenministerrat im Dezember,
weißt du auch keine Einigung zwischen FDP und Union gab Deutschland könnte theoretisch zum Europäischen Gerichtshof gehen jetzt
hat's aber offenbar nicht gemacht, also hat auch keiner vor, glaube ich
als einzelner Bürger ist das ein bisschen schwierig, weil das ist ein Abkommen, was auf europäischer Ebene geschlossen wurde und unmittelbar angewendet wird
Das heißt, es gibt kein deutsches Umsetzungsgesetz gegen das man in Karlsruhe vors Verfassungsgericht ziehen könnte.
Das heißt, wir bleiben theoretisch nur der Weg, gegen irgendwie die Fluglinie zu klagen, dass die oder sich da über die Datenschutzbehörden erstmal zu beschweren, dass die doch meine Daten da uns mäßig rausgeben an die Amerikaner. Die werden dann sagen, nee, müssen wir aber.
Und dann kann man sozusagen den Gang über die Verwaltungsgerichte oder so bis zum Europäischen Gerichtshof und hoffen, dass man Verwaltungsgericht findet, was eben dann zum EuGH vorlegt.
Gerüchteweise ähm sind die Richter im äh Europäischen Gerichtshof in Luxemburg äh inzwischen. Es gibt ja mit dem aber einen Vertrag, auch diese europäische Grundrechte Charta seit Dezember zweitausendneun, die auch B
bindend ist, ähm sind die inzwischen wohl auch offen für Individualbeschwerden. Das hat aber noch keiner so richtig ausprobiert bisher.
Vielleicht jetzt nochmal
weil du ja angangs sagtest, das ist jetzt äh an England, an Spanien und natürlich letztlich auch an anderen Ländern gescheitert.
Welche im Rückblick, welche realistische Chance da einen anderen Weg einzuschlagen
Hat es denn gegeben? Also gibt's hier einen Mangel an Widerstand? Ist das ist da Widerstand äh irgendwie zwecklos gewesen?
Was kann man daraus lernen, jetzt für das generelle Vorgehen, insbesondere bei Themen, die europäische Dimensionen haben.
Ist bisschen schwierig, muss ich gestehen, weil ich auch nicht so ganz den Einblick habe, wie das in anderen Ländern jetzt konkret aussieht mit dem Widerstand mit der Öffentlichkeit. Also ich kann kein Ungarisch oder Spanisch oder so
Nach allem, was ich mitbekommen habe, war es aber schon so, dass diese Debatte darüber sehr kritisch vor allem im deutschsprachigen Raum geführt wurde. Also DGS selber hat ja auch diese Kampagne gemacht, ne
Ähm die Österreicher haben das dann übernommen vom Verein der Internetbenutzer in Österreich und ähnliche. Ähm
Und wenn in Deutschland so eine Debatte läuft, auch in Medien, dann shoppt das ja auch immer schnell nach Österreich über. In anderen Ländern war das nicht so wirklich ein Thema, muss man sagen.
Also da gab's auch, glaube ich, keine großen Aktivistengruppen oder irgendwas, die das äh sich zur Schwerpunktaufgabe gemacht haben.
Das heißt, keine Chance.
Ja, war halt eine schwierige Situation.
Na ja, ich meine, ist ja generell die Frage, wie man eben gegen Sachen, die im Wesentlichen in Europa entschieden werden, äh überhaupt mobilisieren kann. Also, wie schafft man es
Graswurzelbewegungen heraus, eine europäische Dimension zu erreichen.
Das ist schwierig, das ist aber noch im Aufbau und ich glaube, die deutsche Bewegung mit AK Vorrat und so Leuten, ähm da kommen ja auch einige inzwischen regelmäßig nach Brüssel und so. Es gab ja letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal hier in der vier
das ist schon 'ne Situation, die die wo andere Länder nur neidisch draufgucken, ne?
Muss man schon ehrlich sagen. In Polen ist relativ viel Bewegung, der war ja auch der Startschuss sozusagen für die ganzen Acta-Proteste im Januar. Die haben aber anscheinend Brüssel noch nicht so aufm Schirm, zumindest nicht als Massenaktivisten.
Also es ist mühsam, das wird noch ein paar Jahre dauern, bis wir soweit sind, bis wir hier ähm also,
gar nicht mal so unbedingt sozusagen in Brüssel große Demos machen und Aktionen, sondern eher in allen siebenundzwanzig Hauptstädten, weil darauf kommt's dann doch immer noch im Endeffekt an, weil die nationalen Öffentlichkeiten entscheidend sind.
Ich meine, äh realistisch muss man auch sagen, wir haben hier im Moment eine konservative Mehrheit im europäischen Parlament seit der letzten Wahl. Da darf man sich auch nicht allzu viele Illusionen machen.
Gut, dann machen wir das mal nicht.
Eine andere Sache, die wir beide noch über äh über unseren persönlichen Austausch geklärt hatten, war, du wolltest meine Äußerung zur EU Cyber Crime Richtlinien nicht unwidersprochen lassen.
Ein bisschen was zu sagen.
Welche Äußerungen, wo.
Da ging es also um die.
Buch.
Genau, hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik um die ähm Cyber Crime Bekämpfungsmaßnahmen, die jetzt ergriffen werden sollen, wo auch wieder so ein Absatz drin stand, dass der Besitz und das Verbreiten von Hackertools möglichst äh verhindert werden soll.
Und mit Strafen äh belegt werden soll. Da kam dann von dir relativ schnell die Nachricht, dass das äh so nicht hundertprozentig richtig von mir dargestellt wird.
Welche Sendung bezieht sich das jetzt gerade.
Weiß gerade nicht die Nummer verlinken wir dann.
Vor zwei oder drei Wochen, glaube ich, war das.
Ja, das äh ist gar nicht im Vorwurf jetzt an euch, sondern das war generell so mit der Berichterstattung. Es gab äh vor drei Wochen, glaube ich, die äh Orientierungsabstimmung hier im Innenausschuss über diese neue Richtlinien zur Bekämpfung von Cyber-Attacken
und da gab's über hundertdreißig Änderungsanträge,
und ähm das Problem war bei der Berichterstattung darüber, dass einfach diese Konsolidierte Fassung, ne, welcher Änderungsantrag wurde jetzt angenommen und welche wurde abgelehnt und so, wie sieht das denn eigentlich am Ende aus? Die lag überhaupt noch nicht vor. Die habe ich selber auch erst äh vor ein paar Tagen bekommen,
aus dem Ausschuss Sekretariat. Deswegen haben einfach ganz viele jetzt berichtet haben damals, sich auf den ersten Entwurf der Kommission von vorüber einem Jahr gestützt,
Aber der ist eben jetzt mit dieser Abstimmung im Innenausschuss massiv verändert worden. Ähm auch im Innenministerrat, in der Radarbeitsgruppe gab's dazu ähm Änderungswünsche schon letztes Jahr und jetzt,
Am Montag fangen eben erst die Verhandlungen an zwischen Europäischen Parlament und Innenministerrat, wie das Ding dann wirklich am Ende aussehen soll. Und was wir halt ganz gut hingekriegt haben, muss ich schon sagen, ähm bin auch ein bisschen stolz drauf, ich mich auch
bisschen reingehängt habe, ähm ist da eine Reihe von einzubauen. Ähm die dann doch vielleicht ein bisschen beruhigender sind.
Also zum Beispiel, dass ähm äh eindringen in ein Computersystem äh nur dann strafbar ist, wenn eine Sicherheitsschwelle überschritten wird.
Also wenn man irgendwo noch einen einen oder sowas davor hat und ne, also offenes WLAN mitbenutzen oder irgendwo in einen Server reinstolpern, weil da irgendein Verzeichnis offen ist, dass es auf jeden Fall nicht mehr strafbar,
Ähm dann haben wir es geschafft, da war so eine ganz komische Formulierung drinnen, ähm dass äh bei den Hackertools in Artikel sieben.
Genau, das wäre das.
Die weißes, die äh
deutlich dafür hergestellt sind, um solche Straftaten zu begehen
ähm eben dass sozusagen die die Herstellung äh Import äh Verteilung und so weiter äh
strafbar sein sollen. Und wir haben dann die ganze Zeit immer auch die Leute aus der Kommission, die das Ding geschrieben hat und gefragt, was meint ihr denn hier mit Device, was soll denn das sein? Ist das irgendwie so ein Gigabit-Switch, den ich finde, eine Doss-Attacke nutzen kann oder was was meint ihr hier mit Device?
Und dann kam irgendwie lange Zeit gar nichts und dann kam sie irgendwann an äh mit diesen Dingern, die äh vor Bankautomaten geklebt werden, um die PIN-Nummern abzuziehen oder.
Abzulesen, ne? Und so was. Äh sowas Device. Und wir so, hä, das ist eh schon Bankautomaten manipuliert und so. Also, dieses Device ist jetzt rausgeflogen,
glaube ich auch in der Version des Rates draußen. Das ist sozusagen Sicherheitsblatt was noch drinne ist. Leider ist ähm,
immer noch zusammen Hacker Software, aber ähm da haben wir jetzt auch mal auch reingeschrieben, die muss,
sozusagen ganz deutlich für den Zweck äh hergestellt sein, um Straftaten zu begehen.
Also so was wie Software oder so was.
Zum Beispiel, ja, das äh im Endeffekt im Detail wird es dann die nationalen Umsetzungs äh äh Gesetze betreffen, die das klären oder halt die Gerichte.
Also das, das ist genau, denke ich, sehr wichtig. Also, wenn man, wenn man wirklich, sage ich mal, Software zum Erstellen eines Spot Netz hat, die lässt wirklich nur noch einen,
ähm eine Anwendung zu
Aber ähm ich meine, der größere Teil der Hacker Tools, also ähm ist ja genau, wird ja genau von Sicherheits äh Forschern und, und, und, oder Pen-Testern genauso genutzt, um eben genau den Angreifer zu simulieren. Das heißt,
neunundneunzig Komma neun Prozent der Hackersoftware kann ich nicht den Anwendungszweck eindeutig definieren, weil es kann ich brauche sie genauso, um mich dagegen zu schützen, wie ich sie gebrauchen kann, um damit anzugreifen,
und ähm mir fällt da jetzt außer wirklich das Defizite, was schon eine Million Rechner ähm infiziert hat
nichts ein, wo ich sagen könnte, das lässt sich nur zu einem einzigen Zweck verwenden, selbst ähm ein Bordnet kann ich versuchen, ähm irgendwie in mein Firmennetzwerk ähm.
Irgendwie da da äh irgendwie die Infektion dafür hinzubekommen, ja. Ähm.
Na gut, wenn du wenn du solche Tools in deinem eigenen Netz benutzt oder äh sowieso von der Firma autorisiert bist, diese Tests durchzuführen, dann ist, bist du sowieso im grünen Bereich, das ist von der Richtlinie komplett ausgenommen.
Aber dafür brauche ich sie in meinem Besitz.
Ja Besitz ist auch nicht mehr strafbarer. Ähm das haben wir rausgestrichen. Ähm es ist nur noch strafbar der Import, äh die Verteilung oder die anderweitige zur Verfügung.
Das ist wie bei Drogen, ja? Okay, Besitz ist nicht wirklich strafbar, es sei denn in kleinen Mengen.
Bedarf, genau.
Das heißt, äh so wenn wir uns das anschauen, Drogen sind ja jetzt doch schon irgendwie äh
ähm sage ich mal, relativ illegal, ja, also man kann dass dass man sie jetzt vielleicht noch besitzen darf in kleinen Mengen, ähm hat jetzt nicht zur großen äh Entkriminalisierung äh geführt in dem Bereich. Also wenn man das jetzt mit Hacker Programm genauso macht, ähm.
Ja, es ist hier schon noch ein bisschen anders, weil ähm da auch noch drin steht, ist ja stand übrigens auch schon die ganze Zeit drin, hat bloß keiner gelesen. Ähm dass diese ganzen Sachen, also sie zur Verfügungstellung, der Import und
weiter von solchen Tools ähm nur dann strafbar ist, wenn es mit dem äh klaren Zweck gemacht wird, dass Leute damit Straftaten begehen.
Ja aber was soll denn.
Wenn ich sozusagen als als äh wie jemand, der so ein Ding verteilt vorher schon weiß, der, dem ich jetzt gebe, der macht damit irgendwas böses.
Sagen wir, ich stelle, nehmen wir ein populäres Beispiel. Ich stelle irgendwie eine Pentasting-Distribution, Backtrack-Linux äh zu zum Download zur Verfügung
fünfundneunzig Prozent der Leute nutzen das wahrscheinlich zum Fantasting. Fünf Prozent sind Skript-Kities, die damit irgendwie dann äh versuchen ähm ihre Klassenkameraden anzugreifen.
Ja, würde ich sagen, bist du raus. Dann bist du von von dem hier nicht erfasst, von dem was.
Würde ich so lesen. Also ich meine, wir haben versucht als Grüne Fraktion äh den Artikel sieben komplett rauszuschmeißen. Wir hatten da einen Änderungsantrag, um einfach zu streichen.
Haben wir leider bloß keine Mehrheit bekommen, ne? Und jetzt ist uns halt immerhin so ein paar Safeguards drin gelandet, die Hardware Hacker Hardware ist rausgeflogen. Ähm insofern,
Ist es glaube ich nicht mehr ganz so furchtbar wie am Anfang. Und die Sache gab's ja auch übrigens vorher schon und das passiert ja alles auf einer Richtlinie von, ich glaube, zweitausendfünf ähm,
erinnern und nicht nach Richtlinien einen Rahmenbeschluss des äh Innenministerrates, die haben das damals schon mal gemacht, seitdem sind ja sozusagen Hackertools auch europaweit schon kriminalisiert und auf der Basis ja vor ein paar Jahren auch in Deutschland der äh
zwohundertzwo C Strafgesetzbuch eingeführt worden, obwohl in Deutschland ein relativ intensive Debatte hatten. Das ist sozusagen äh
Die Situation gibt's schon länger, das passiert ja auch zum Teil auf der Cyber Crime Richtlinie des Europarates von zweitausend. Insofern
War's ja auch schwierig dann zu sagen, nee, diesen Teil schmeißen wir komplett wieder raus, ne. Wir haben's halt jetzt hingekriegt, immerhin da ein paar Safe Guards einzubauen.
Und das das eben auch noch für ein paar andere Stellen, also ähm.
Es gab dann ähm einen äh Antrag zum Beispiel, ich glaube, der kam sogar hier von einem,
Parlament von einer Fraktion, dass die nicht autorisierte Nutzung von Computersystemen auch äh unter diese Richtlinie fallen soll und strafbar sein soll.
Also nicht nur das Eindringen oder Abhören oder stören oder sowas, sondern eben auch die nicht autorisierte Nutzung. Und dann haben uns die Leute von der Electronic Front hier Foundation darauf aufmerksam gemacht, ähm mit denen wir dann,
Austausch hatten so 'n ähnlichen gibt's im amerikanischen Recht schon im Computer,
und äh das hat dann dazu geführt, dass einfach ein Verstoß gegen allgemeine Geschäftsbedingungen als nicht autorisierte Nutzung verstanden wurde und die Leute haben plötzlich strafrechtlich dran waren,
oder oder wenn jemand äh irgendwie am Arbeitsplatz einen Rechner stehen hat und der Arbeitgeber aber ganz klar gesagt hat, hier du darfst hier nur für dienstliche Zwecke benutzen und der hat dann doch mal kurz irgendwie in der Mittagspause oder was auf Facebook nachgeguckt oder so
dann war das sozusagen eine nicht autorisierte Nutzung dieses Computers und der war plötzlich vom Strafrichter, ne, nicht nur vom Arbeitsrecht da. Ähm,
Das sind auch die Amerikaner selber jetzt gerade dabei, ähm das Ding wieder zu fixen. Die haben da irgendwie paar Änderungen äh beantragt jetzt im Senat, um das zu reparieren. Ähm da haben wir eben auch äh gesagt, dass äh muss auf jeden Fall ausgeschlossen werden, dass solche Sachen da betroffen sind und das ist jetzt auch
zumindest in der Parlamentsposition drin. Ich hoffe, da können wir uns mit den Innenministern auch einigen, weil das kann ja irgendwie keiner wollen.
Alles klar, dann würde ich sagen, wünschen wir euch dabei viel Erfolg.
Montag gehen die Verhandlungen los zwischen Parlamentenrat, dann müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich werde auch mit übrigens ganz kurz noch äh den vielleicht auch ein paar kennen aus anderen Umständen,
Berlin und so. Äh der war hier auch auf einer Anhörung äh im Oktober und hat da irgendwie ziemlich gerockt und äh
der ist ja auch seit zehn Jahren als da unterwegs und so. Äh mit dem zusammen äh werde ich auf der Republika und auf der SiegInd dazu auch einen Vortrag machen und nochmal ein bisschen genauer erzählen, äh
gelaufen ist und was es so für lustige Begebenheiten am Rande noch gab und so.
Wann seid ihr dran?
Oh, ich weiß nicht, im Kopf. Keine Ahnung. Äh Republikaner, glaube ich, Freitag äh ist noch offen.
Republika ist, zweiter bis vierter Mai in Berlin in der Station und.
Ist achtzehnter bis zwanzigster.
Bis zwanzigster in Köln.
So sieht's aus. Vielen Dank Ralph für die Einblicke. Wir äh kommen gerne mal wieder auf dich zurück, wenn sich äh neue Dinge ergeben.
Juni, Juli, kommt ja aktuell, ne?
Ah jetzt nicht nur.
Liebeskrieg.
Ist ein guter Zeitpunkt bis dahin haben wir wieder durchgeatmet. Okay, Ralf, vielen Dank.
Ralf, vielen Dank. Ralf, vielen Dank. Ciao, ciao.
Ja
Das war unser Mann vor Ort, in unserer Korrespondent in Brüssel. Lokbuchnetzpolitik äh entwickelt sich hier langsam zu einem äh veritablen News Network. Ja, das bringt uns dann zum nächsten Thema.
Zum eigentlich großen Thema der Woche. Genau. Vorrat.
Genau und es ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Alle gehen. Was ist passiert? Andre, WhatsApp.
Die Vorratszeitenspeicherung mal wieder beschäftigt ja uns schon eine ganze, ganze Weile diese unsägliche EU-Richtlinie gibt's seit zwotausendsechs.
Hier in Deutschland wurde ja schon mal ein Umsetzungsgesetz gestartet. Vom Bundesverfassungsgericht wieder verworfen seitdem heißt es immer, ja wir müssen das neu machen.
Ähm.
Drei Wochen kam der, kam der Druckbrief.
Genau, die EU schickt auch mittlerweile einen Drohbrief. Wenn das nicht bis nächste Woche Donnerstag äh die Umsetzung läuft, dann drohen Strafzahlungen.
Nächste Woche Donnerstag ist der sechsundzwanzigste April.
Nee, dann drohen nicht Strafzeilen, dann droht eine Klage vor dem EuGH und da könnten unter Umständen Strafzahlungen bei rauskommen. Also diese Strafzahlungsargument ähm ist eigentlich eine schon sehr äh Panik.
Panik behaftet, oder?
Naja, ich glaube, Schweden hat tatsächlich Strafzahlungen bekommen, aber um das mal im Kontext zu rücken, ähm ist,
derzeit ist ja auch auf EU-Ebene die Initiative diese Richtlinie zu überarbeiten
Es wurde uns schon lang versprochen, dass das fertig ist. Schon letztes Jahr im Dezember. Mittlerweile heißt's von der Kommission im Juni oder Juli soll es eine neue Version dieser Richtlinie geben und
quasi in Torschusspanik ähm kurz nochmal die Richtlinie umzusetzen, obwohl gar nicht aus äh klar ist, wie die in zwei Monaten aussieht
kann man getrost als verfrüht und vergebliche Liebesmühe betrachten und zumal
Das Gericht, das über die Strafteilungen entscheidet, der EUGH auch das Gericht ist, äh wo noch eine Klage von Irland anhängig ist
um überhaupt die Richtlinie in ihrer Substanz zu beurteilen, ist die mit der europäischen äh Menschenrechtskater vereinbar.
So und wir erinnern uns trotzdem, hat jetzt quasi der Friedrich ähm der oder wie das wie das heißt, hat ja dann ähm,
mehr oder weniger das äh bestellt, diese diese Beschwerde, ja? Ähm von von der EU, weil weil ja irgendwie angefragt wurde im Rahmen der
Evaluation der aktuellen Richtlinie wie es da aussieht und dann hat er irgendwie so geschrieben, bitte bitte Hilfe, schreib mal
und jetzt kommt dieser Druck und in einer Woche soll's soweit sein. Und jetzt gibt's ein
Entwurf zur Ausgestaltung der Richtlinie vom Justizministerium, Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger und einen von Friedrich.
Innenminister und was ist da jetzt genau der Unterschied? Also vielleicht müsste man anfangen, was will die EU-Richtlinie? Was will das Justizministerium und was will das Innenministerium?
Die EU-Richtlinie sagt ziemlich deutlich, äh und da hat das Innenministerium äh eher recht,
Provider in der EU sollen dazu verpflichtet werden für sechs Monate,
jegliche Verbindungsdaten, elektronische Kommunikation, quasi Telefon, SMS, Kurznachrichten, E-Mails äh zu speichern, wann, wer mit wem
wie lange welche IP, wem welche IP-Adresse zugeordnet.
Also also du hattest das, glaube ich, in deinem Artikel so geschrieben bei Telefon und SMS, wann, wer mit wem wohl, in welchen Funkzellen die beiden Personen waren und welche Geräte sie genutzt haben.
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder der Innenministeriums äh Vorschlag. Ähm das steht ähnlich,
in der EU-Richtlinie. Äh wie gesagt, schon seit zwotausendsechs und das war hier ja auch schon mal in Gesetzesform gegossen.
Die Justiz das Justizministerium will das so nicht flächendeck überdeckende Überwachung jeglicher Telekommunikation,
die äh für unverhältnismäßig und ein Eingriff in äh ja informationelle Selbstbestimmung, will stattdessen einen sogenannten oder quick Plus Vorschlag.
Ähm das gehört eigentlich zusammen, aber um das mal kurz zu trennen, ähm geht's einerseits darum,
nachvollziehbar zu machen, wer hatte wann welche IP beziehungsweise andersrum, wenn ich eine IP habe, wer ist der Anschlussinhaber dahinter?
Das hat das Mietministerium vorgeschlagen, könnte man mal für sieben Tage speichern und wenn's dann einen Grund gibt, auf diese Daten zuzugreifen, könnte man das Quickfree einfrieren lassen und danach darauf zugreifen, mit Richterbeschluss ähm,
und den Anschlussinhaber in hinter einer IP äh zu ermitteln,
noch viel weitergehender ist aber der von mir sogenannte Horrorkatalog tatsächlich prophylaktisch von jedem Anruf, jeder SMS und jeder E-Mail zu speichern, wer ist Absender, wer ist Empfänger,
Ähm wann war das? Wie lange ging das? Welche IP oder welche Funkzelle wurde dabei benutzt?
Und der kommt vom Innenministerium.
Steht in der EU-Rischlinie und den will natürlich das Innenministerium so auch haben, ganz klar, die sind auf der Seite der Ordnungspolitiker und
Der Staat ist gut und braucht das zur Durchsetzung und er macht auch niemals Fehler. Deswegen müssen wir das speichern. Man könnte es ja mal äh brauchen wollen.
So und was ähm jetzt haben wir aber irgendwo ja noch ein ein Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts,
sich damals mit der konkreten Ausgestaltung der Richtlinie in Deutschland ähm auseinandergesetzt hat, gesagt hat, so geht das schon mal nicht. Und das aus diesem Urteil ging ja im Prinzip Handlungsempfehlungen hervor, wie man eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestalten muss.
Um sie in Deutschland durchsetzen zu können. Lässt der Vorschlag des Bundesinnenministeriums irgendwie erahnen, dass sie sich damit auseinandergesetzt haben.
Also um vorweg nochmal, ihr, äh da begeben wir uns jetzt äh im Graubereich. Es sind auch noch nicht der komplette Entwurf
oder Antwort vom Innenministerium tatsächlich im Internet öffentlich, sondern nur Teile davon.
Natürlich werden die sich damit auseinandergesetzt haben, die können nicht ankommen und einfach Copy und Paste das alte Gesetz nehmen, sonst wären die vom Justizministerium gleich ausgelacht und haben gesagt, hier ihr habt ja noch nicht mal die Anforderungen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht erfüllt
Also tatsächlich werden diese schon was dabei gedacht haben. Nur zwei Juristen, drei Meinungen,
auch in BMI werden einige Sätze des Bundesverfassungsgericht,
ähm vielleicht mal anders interpretiert als im Justizministerium,
Alba hat so 'n Gegenüberstellung gemacht von dem alten Gesetz, dieser Vorratszeitensprechung, was es ja schon mal gab.
Also Alva, Freude.
Freude auf Blog Odem ORG. Ähm.
Er hat das gegenüber gestellt, mit dem Teil des äh BMI Referenten Feedbacks, was jetzt öffentlich geworden ist
und das sieht tatsächlich in großen Teilen nach Copy und Paste mit geringfügigen Änderungen aus. Das ist aber auch nicht,
der komplette Teil des BMI BMI Papiers und da ist auf dem Entwurf von BMJ Justizministerium.
Basiert sind da auch in anderen Teilen noch ähm Safeguards drin, wie die Daten müssen vorsichtiger gespeichert werden,
beziehungsweise der Zugriff nicht ganz so häufig und so und es gibt irgendwie Schutzanordnung, dass die Daten nicht mehr für jeden kleinen popeligen Mitarbeiter,
zu erreichen sind und so im Detail wurde dieses Papier noch nicht in ganz juristisch ausgewertet deswegen mit genauen juristischen Aussagen auch noch zurückhalten,
beim ersten Durchsehen ist aber zum Beispiel nicht ersichtlich geworden, ob damit äh zum Beispiel,
Schutzbedürftige Kommunikation wie telefonische Beratungsstellen, Seelsorge, Drogenberatung, Schwangerschaftsberatung, Anwalts-, Juristengeheimnis, Journalisten,
Quellenschutz und so ob diese irgendwie gesundes geschützt wären, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht zum Beispiel angemahnt hat,
Fleißarbeit das mit dem Urteil abzuklären aber nochmal zum Prozess zu kommen dieses Ministerium hat ja schon lange,
ihr Vorschlag gemacht. Ähm bisher wollte sich das Innenministerium gar nicht darauf einlassen, das als Diskussionsgrundlage überhaupt zu nehmen,
dann hat Merkel ein Machtwort gesprochen und hat gesagt, doch, nimm das mal als Diskussionsgrundlage und das Innenministerium hat das eben nach seinen Wünschen umgeschrieben.
Sie hat aber, genau, sie hat ja gleichzeitig auch ihr Machtwort nicht nur in Richtung des Innenministeriums gesprochen, sondern auch in Richtung damals Philipp Rößler in Anwesenheit von Sabine Leuthäuser, Schnarrenberger, ihm relativ klar gesagt, sieh mal zu, dass du hier deine ähm Pappenheimer unter Kontrolle kriegst. So
äh könnte man das mal frei übersetzen, ne.
Also,
ich glaube im Justizministerium war man über das Feedback aus dem Innenministerium Nordam Yoused, wie man so schön sagt, also,
die haben tatsächlich ja, die haben jetzt Copy und Paste vom Originalvorschlag gemacht, das ist das, was wir schon immer gesagt haben, wollen wir nicht. Das ist das, wo gegen die Justizministerin geklagt hat.
Ist fraglich,
wie diese beiden Extrempositionen ähm also Sabine Schnarrenberger mit ihrem Quickfree Plus tatsächlich ist sie eine mini drin von sieben Tage IP-Adresse Anschlussinhaber, Zuordnung, über die man sich,
zurecht streiten kann.
Und sechs Monate alles, jede Mail, jede E-Mail, jeder äh jede SMS, jeder Telefonanruf, wie man es irgendwie zusammenkriegen kann, ist fraglich, wahrscheinlich wird,
zu den nächsten zwei Landtagswahlen nichts passieren, denn die FDP könnte sich das nicht erlauben äh jetzt da irgendwie auch nur ein Strohhalm zu geben an das Innenministerium,
Ob die danach irgendwie zusammenkommen können, wird, ja, wird zu sehen sein. Es ist fraglich. Die brauchen auf alle Fälle,
Druck, dem nicht zuzustimmen, auch wenn das über die,
mittelfristige Zukunft nicht so gut aussieht. Also der nächste Bundestag, egal wie der aussieht, für den hab ich noch nicht so viel Vertrauen, das würde irgendwie nach drei Jahren immer noch über Quickfrees debattieren. Ich glaube, das wird.
Leider ziemlich schnell gehen, deswegen müssen wir die EU-Richtlinie angehen. Äh erstens.
Hier wird ja gerade noch überarbeitet, auch wenn leider in der Überarbeitung anscheinend die wichtigen Fragen wie,
will man das überhaupt? Bringt das was? Gibt es tatsächlich empirische Belege abseits von ist nützlich in Einzelfällen,
dafür, dass man das unbedingt braucht? Will man das für den Terrorismus, mit dem das mal begründet wurde oder gegen jegliche Straftaten, die man mal damit aufklären könnte oder sogar oder so,
ähm oder wollen wir wollen wir äh Nationalstaaten entscheiden lassen, ob sie das umsetzen wollen oder nicht, ähnlich wie bei Zensilia, Internetsperren,
Das sind alles Fragen, die die Richtlinie äh klären muss,
werden wir gucken, wie die aussieht. Ich habe nicht allzu viele Hoffnungen, deswegen gibt's auch noch Bestrebungen, die Richtlinie an sich anzugehen, zum Beispiel mit einer europäischen Bürgerinitiative, die seit ersten April möglich ist, wo man,
ähnlich wie eine Petition hier,
wo die Bürger der EU sagen können, hallo Brüssel, wir hätten gern, dass ihr diese Policy äh mal ja.
Darüber mal diskutiert und gerne auch, dass ihr euch so entscheidet,
wofür man eine Million Unterschriften in mindestens sieben nee quatsch in allen Staaten allen siebenundzwanzig Mitgliedsstaaten jeweils aber mit bestimmten Schwellwerten sammeln muss. Also das sind wahnsinniger Aufwand,
Aber die Idee ist, dass eventuell zu machen, nicht um in erster Linie tatsächlich inhaltlich das Ding sofort zu kippen, aber um zu zeigen, ey, hier sind Hunderttausende, wenn nicht sogar Millionen von EU-Bürgern, die wollen das nicht, um dann mit diesem Rückhalt eventuell,
ähm diese Richtlinie nochmal anzugehen, denn die ist das Grundübel.
Jetzt hast du gerade schon das angesprochen im Vorgespräch. Haben gesagt, wir wollen da gar nicht so weit drauf äh das gar nicht so so groß zum Thema machen. Aber es gab gestern,
Urteil des EUGH
wo sie gesagt haben, ähm dass es eventuell den Nationalstaaten erlaubt sein sollte, Daten, die im Rahmen der Fortsdatenspeicherung anfallen, auch wenn diese nicht dafür gedacht ist,
zu nutzen, wenn es das nationale Recht erlaubt, um.
Identifikation von eventuell beschuldigten Personen vorzunehmen.
Vorsichtig ausgedrückt, aber ich glaube immer noch nicht hundertprozentig korrekt. Wir sind jetzt alle keine Juristen
und die werden uns wahrscheinlich dafür einen auf den Deckel geben. Eine Zusammenfassung und Übersicht ist in dem Netzpolitikartikel, den ich gestern gepostet habe. Europäischer Gerichtshof erlaubt Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegen Firesharing.
Klammer ein Update.
Also ich habe da die ganz große ähm Hautraufkeule rausgeholt. Ähm die die Juristen werden das nochmal im Detail klären. Worum es ging ist, dass äh ein schwedischer ISP ähm,
Inhaberdaten von der IP rausrücken sollte, über den siebenundzwanzig Audio äh über die siebenundzwanzig Audiofiles getauscht worden. Äh und der ISP hat gesagt,
'ne Zuordnung IP zu Inhaber, das ist ja Vorratsdatenspeicherung und das ist nur für Terrorismus.
OK also doch tatsächlich 'ne.
Der EuGH.
Frage, ja.
Hat gesagt, nee, nee, die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie untersagt nicht, dass ein nationales Gesetz erlauben kann, äh solche Daten auch äh zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverletzungen heranzuziehen.
Es hätte die Möglichkeit gehabt, nee, nee, in der Richtlinie steht klipp und klar, solche Daten äh nur dafür,
da ja die Vorratsseitensprechungsrichtlinie mal mit Binnenmarkt begründet wurde, dass die Provider das ganz europäisch äh gleichmachen,
müssen, sonst gebe es da Marktverzerrungen und so, auch nur wenn man's über die Sicherheitspolitik nicht durchbekommen hat. Aber hier hätte es die Möglichkeit gegeben, über das Binnenmarktargument auch zu sagen,
Nein, das ist ganz klar im ähm Bezugsrahmen der Vorratszeiten Speicherungsrichtlinie und die sieht das nicht vor, haben die nicht gemacht.
Okay, da sei dann nochmal auf die Artikel die beiden Artikel einmal von Thomas Stadler und glaube ich noch mehr von Sebastian Dusch,
verwiesen, die du auch verlinkt hast und wir auch im äh in denen's Shownotes zu dieser unserer Sendung. Ähm.
Ein letztes kurzes Thema, was ich ganz gerne noch ansprechen würde, ist der
Gesetzesentwurf gegen das Abmahnen um Unwesen, ja? Also und zwar geht es um das ähm rechtliche Mittel der Abmahnung, dass dass eigentlich mal
aus gar nicht so blöden Gründen existiert. Es geht irgendwie darum, jemand.
Tut etwas äh was wo ich davon ausgehe, dass das meine meine Rechte als Bürger verletzt und ähm.
Diese diese Tätigkeit, was er da macht hält an ja, also weiß ich, ich werde in der Bildzeitung fertig gemacht mit mit falschen Behauptungen
dann könnte ich natürlich jetzt irgendwie klagen oder so, dass das zieht sich dann über Jahre hin oder ich kann gegen so etwas mit mit einer Abmahnung vorgehen, wo ich irgendwie einen Streitwert festsetze
und ähm.
Diesen Schritt mache, zu sagen, lass das sein, ähm zahl diese und jene Gebühr an mich und ähm die Sache ist damit durch.
Und dann kann der Empfänger der Abmahnung sagen, ne, pass mal auf, ich fühle, ich denke, dass das, was ich hier gerade mache, äh gesetzlich in Ordnung ist. Und ich lasse es auf einen ähm Verfahren ankommen.
Ich fechte diese Abmahnung an. Ähm das heißt also für für eilende, dringende Dinge ist so eine Artung irgendwie gedacht.
Und leider hat dieses Mittel so ein bisschen den äh eine Industrie.
Ähm hervorgebracht von von Anwälten, die sich nur darauf spezialisieren
Abmahnungen zu verschicken, weil diese dann sich nach dem nach dem festgesetzten Streitwert irgendwie ergibt sich dann Anwaltshonorar und dann kann man mit den äh jeweiligen, mit seinen Klienten quasi noch fifty-fifty über die Kohle machen, die man sonst noch da rausholt
und haben da irgendwie so eine Art,
Geschäftsmodell draus gemacht, Massenabmahnungen an, aber auch zum Beispiel an Betreiber von Onlineshops. Also es war irgendwie eine sehr beliebte Masche, als irgendwann mal umgestellt wurde, dass man bei Online-Shops nicht.
Vierzehn Tage Rückgaberecht hat, sondern einen Monat.
Und dann konnte man quasi, wenn man einen Onlineshop hatte, andere Online-Shops abmahnen, die.
Das nicht haben, die also quasi noch die alten AG in ihren alten AGBs drinstehen haben vierzehn Tage Rückgaberecht.
Wettbewerbsvorteil desjenigen, der sich nicht an das Gesetz hält und nur vierzehn Tage Rückgaberecht einräumt, dann kann ich also sagen, als jemand, der sich ans Gesetz hält und ein Monat Rückgaberecht einräumt,
Konkurrenten mahne ich ab,
und einem guten Freund von mir ist das deshalb ist es passiert, weil er Produkte auf eBay verkauft hat, also er war Online-Händler und hat dann auch noch Produkte auf eBay verkauft und dann hagelte es für ihn von allen möglichen Seiten Abmahnungen.
Für abgelaufene Aktionen auf äh Auktionen auf eBay. Die bleiben ja dann noch sechzig Tage drin.
Kann man nicht mehr ändern. Also da da stand dann quasi die AGBs in der Auktion drin und diese Daten konnte er nicht nachträglich ändern.
Und dann ist quasi der erste Abmahnanwalt gekommen und hat gesagt, super, hier ähm dich mal nicht ab, auch wirklich ein völlig utopischen Betrag, ja?
Und dann hat er sich offensichtlich in irgendein Forum ausgetauscht und dann kriegt er mein lieber Freund von mehreren verschiedenen Abmahnanwälten dann Abmahnungen wegen.
Wegen dieser äh wegen dieser nicht zulässigen AGBs, weil er irgendwie einmal eins, zwei, drei Produkte auf eBay verkauft hat. Der hat am Ende ein paar tausend Euro Minus gemacht und diese ähm Klienten,
Strohmänner, die im Prinzip dahinter standen, die hatten halt irgendwie kurz eine Webseite aufgesetzt, die halt ähnliche Produkte verkauft hat, aber nie wirklich ernsthaft im Geschäft war. Und,
Da sieht man glaube ich ähm im Vergleich auch zu den zu den sehr häufig anzutreffenden Abmahnungen, die ja auch sehr hohe äh Gebühren dann nach sich ziehen, dass da offensichtlich etwas.
Ein Rechtsmittel irgendwie aus dem aus Rand außer Rand und Band ist, ja? Und dagegen möchte sich jetzt das Justizministerium mit einem,
Gesetzesentwurf wenden und möchte zum Beispiel dafür sorgen,
dass die Streitwerte in bestimmten Bereichen, also Urheberrecht und solchen Dingen,
gedeckelt sind bei fünfhundert Euro, das heißt, da bleiben dann irgendwie noch siebzig Euro für den Anwalt nach Gebührenordnung. Das heißt, diese diese Abmahnungen sollen mal wieder so ein bisschen auf den zurück auf den Boden der Tatsachen geholt werden.
Ähm außerdem soll der zu ein zu Unrecht abgemahnter äh die Kosten für den,
für den von ihm eingeschalteten Rechtsanwalt zurückerstattet bekommen. Mir war gar nicht klar, dass das äh noch nicht der Fall war bisher.
Und ein weiteres Problem bei diesen Abmahnungen war der fliegende Gerichtsstand, sodass ich mir für meine,
Filesharing Abmahnungen im im Internet, im Prinzip jedes Gericht in Deutschland aussuchen konnte,
solange dort diese auch erreichbar war übers Internet und das ist ja in der Regel der Fall, das Internet hat ja eine relativ hohe Durchdringungskraft und da war glaube ich, dass äh.
OLG oder LG Hamburg oder irgendwelche Leute in Hamburg waren immer sehr beliebt,
weil man bei denen wusste, ähm wenn da irgendwie eine Urheberrechtssache, Abmahnung und so weiter,
landet, dann sind die sehr freudig äh da zuzustimmen. Also hat man massenhaft irgendwie,
mit diesem Gericht stand an Leute Abmahnungen verschickt und eigentlich konnte das ganze Land,
wenn es jeder, der so einen Brief bekommen hat, der hatte nur die Option, dann wirklich zu zahlen. Das waren teilweise halt sehr, sehr hohe Beträge.
Diese frohe freie Wahl soll eben auch eingeschränkt werden und in andererseits soll aber bei unerlaubten Werbeaufrufen äh irgendwie mal ein bisschen höhere Streitwerte auch erlaubt werden. Das heißt, man sieht auch da wirklich bei diesem Gesetzesentwurf,
die Handschrift, so des des Bürgerrechts der Bürgerrechtsbetonung, ne, des Schutzes irgendwo der des Verbraucherschutzes, ja? Ähm.
Da der kursierte also gerade und natürlich auch dort ein Streit in unserer äh,
Regierungskoalition zwischen der FDP, die also sagt, wir möchten das ganz gerne so durchsetzen,
und der Koalitionspartner CDU, der auch in diesem Fall eher auf der Seite der Rechteverwerter steht, für die das ja so ein bisschen die neue Einkommensquelle ist, ähm wenn die Leute unsere Sachen schon nicht kaufen, dann holen wir uns die Kohle heute, indem wir sie abmahnen, was ja auch äh zumindest nachvollziehbar ist
CDU scheint da also auch eher auf dieser Seite zu sein, das heißt da haben wir noch einen zweiten Punkt, an dem sich jetzt,
auch wieder das Justizministerium mit der ähm CDU anlegt.
Hat da also entweder hat sie eine Menge Spaß, je nachdem, wie sie so drauf ist oder gar keinen, es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, aber auf jeden Fall äh stellt sie da so ein bisschen auch das gallische Dorf äh innerhalb dieser Regierung da.
Ja, also das wirklich der einzige traurige Aspekt des Niederganges der FDP, dass äh dass man.
Dann später keinen Job kriegt.
Ja, dass man der Frau da offensichtlich verlustig geht, ne? Weil ähm ich meine, sie ist sich in jeder.
Zum Piraten wechseln.
Ich meine, sie ja, können, das steht hier ja offen, dann müsste sie sich nur von ihrer äh Position zum Leistungsschutzrecht ja leider verabschieden, ne? Da hat's.
Stimmt allerdings.
Also sie ist da beim Leistungsschutzrecht, weil sie ja sehr dafür ähm hat aber dann nachher auf dem Bundesparteitag, wenn ich das richtig stehe, äh dieses Leistungsschutzrecht, diese Position nicht in der FDP verankern können. Ähm.
Aber was was grundsätzlich so so diese Bürgerrechtssachen und Verbraucherschutzsachen angeht, ähm ist diese Frau äh.
Im Moment mehr wird als die gesamte FDP, denke ich mal.
Allerdings.
Na ja, leider äh sehe ich im Moment keine Perspektive für sie, äh weiterhin Justizministerin zu bleiben und das äh lässt uns in eine relativ schwarze Zukunft blicken.
Ja oder eine schwarz-rote Zukunft.
Das so genau anschaut, wie es derzeit ist so, aber äh niemand weiß, was die Zukunft bringt. Schauen wir mal, wie sich das alles äh entwickelt. Ansonsten, ihr habt den Eindruck, wir sind äh durch hier mit unserem harten Tobac.
Das war heute wirklich harter Tor. Ich glaube, wir haben selten eine Hertha-Tobacca-Sendung gehabt als heute.
Ja. Mal gucken, ob uns noch ein lustiger Titel einfällt. Harter Tobak. Andre, vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Und ja, so geht's weiter. Nächste Woche senden wir wieder, ob wir was zur Republika machen, wissen wir noch nicht so ganz genau. Ähm das wird sich zeigen. Wir lassen uns da noch inspirieren,
Vielleicht auch von euch äh vielen Dank auf jeden Fall ähm
für Kommentare, Berichtigungen, Anregungen, Tipps, Vorschläge, Mutzusprechung, Befletterung und was ihr sonst alles noch so leistet für diesen Kanal,
Linus, ich denke, das war's, oder?
Das war's. Ja, komm, Feierabend hier. Tschau, tschau.
Alles klar, bis bald, tschüss.